gentlemen in the final level of this
competition we're asking you to make a
short sword and we're asking you to make
it out of this
pieces of large high carbon steel and
small high carbon steel
one of the large pieces of Steel
Additionally you must choose at least
one of these jars of Steel upon
completion of this challenge your
weapons will be tested in a pig carcass
kill test copper pipe chop and rubber
tube slice
gentlemen you have only eight hours to
complete all of this work make us
something that's functional that feels
good but is also beautiful good luck
bladesmiths your eight hour Starts Now
what I'm choosing for my big steel is a
leaf spring it's relatively in the shape
that I want it's a great steel for
knives or swords
and then I'm going to go straight to the
1095 powder and ball bearings and make a
canister and I'm using white out too
that there's a solid coating between the
canister and the hardenable material
inside of it
so I want to put my canister which I'm
starting to draw out on top and on
bottom and in the center I have a nice
pristine piece of the high Carbon Leaf
Spring that's going to stick out the
edges and be my Edge
this is a home Forge build done in one
day it's a mountain declined almost
three hours into this competition and
these guys are still cutting and
stacking and Welding trying to create
those 25 layers I've got the blade to
shape I use the oxy acetylene torch to
make sure the tip and Fang are all the
same Heat
Ben has quenched
John has quenched
I pulled my blade out of the temper I
think I'm good I've got a nice golden
color top that blade looks really really
straight good very smart work good to go
now that my blade is tempered it's time
to start hogging off some steel
good flat Platinum 30 minutes blade
Smiths 30 minutes remaining
slow process hopefully we'll all come
together and we'll get this baby glued
up I know he doesn't have an edge on
that blade yet but still scared well
it's getting the hell out of me
oh at least he's got all his safety
glasses and he'll keep that arterial
spray out of his eyes
John needs to turn a nine towards Beauty
as well as strength as well as sharpness
paint guard is so
tiny it looks like he welded extensions
on a wing neck yeah
so Ben has just pulled this blade out of
the edge looks like he's hitting there
with a little steel wool over here sweet
one Ray Smith shut down your machine
stop what you're doing this competition
is over late Smiths welcome to the Keel
test well it's time to find out what
kind of lethal damage your short swords
will do to find that out I will take
your weapons and deliver some lethal
slashes and thrusts on this big carcass
John you're first you ready let's do it
let's do this
I think I've got a fairly sharp blade
but swinging a blade through ribs spine
it can do a lot of damage to a blade I'm
a nervous wreck at this point
all right yes
I'll take it
all right John talk about your short
sword here
The Edge is sharp those are very deep
cuts
your guard is slightly offset and
there are a few gaps that you can see
right there on the guard but overall
your sword
will kill thank you Ben are you ready
for this yes sir I am let's do this
my blade is sharp the handle is solid I
spend a lot of time on the heat treat so
I'm confident of its strength
mostly but Doug could hit a bone in the
pig and it could chip a piece out of my
blade so I'm really nervous
all right Ben let's talk about your
short sword here are your Regis
are very sharp
so close to dropping the pig all the way
but nonetheless you can see the other
cuts are very deep feels good it's quick
it's fast and it's balanced now your
handle construction I like the leather
that you put around this it really is a
good fit overall sir your weapon
will kill
bladesmiths welcome to a strength test
the copper pipe chop copper can tear up
Edge is real easy so it's going to test
your heat treat as well as the overall
construction of your swords now as
normal what your blades do to the pipes
I don't care about that really I want to
see what the pipes I can do to your
blades John you're up first how you
feeling anxious ready to go though I'm
ready too let's do it
my sword is now in the hands of Jay
Nielsen and he is chomping at the bit to
destroy some swords today
oh
ah
look at that that was a bolt
all right John your Edge survived no
problem
um the handle's a bit of an issue for me
you see your guard is kind of over here
your pummel's kind of going this way a
little bit it's definitely on the Rough
Side
but it's strong good job thank you all
right Ben you ready
come on you've done this before yeah
yeah I'm ready
oh
foreign
you survived good job no damage on the
Edge at all
uh your steel looks great your handle is
very comfortable and uh
it's tough sword good job thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
sharpness test the rubber tube slice now
this test is all about what your weapons
do to that Target I want to see good
clean slices through there John Europe
first you ready ready okay
there we go
yes all right nice job
all right John right off sword's got a
great Edge on it cuts beautifully the
transition from the handle to the guard
is a little rough and and there's what
looks to be I think glue that actually
is a kind of a Sharp rough Edge but uh
as far as function goes well done thank
you all right Ben it's your turn you
ready for this let's do it okay
oh [ __ ]
damn nowhere
right so Ben right off it's definitely
got a sharp edge it cut through that
first pipe fine it's a clean cut all the
way through it but those tubes absorb a
lot of energy and it bounced back on me
uh your handle has a great look to it
also feels really good it's definitely
sharp good job thank you
I think my blade performed as well as
bends but there's more to this
competition than that Ben has got me on
the fit and finish but I really want to
win this all right gentlemen the judge's
deliberation is complete they've made
their final decision
the winner of this competition is
two-time Fords and fire Champion Ben
Abbott
well John you won't be leaving with 10
grand this time Jay Nielsen is going to
tell you why John both displays
performed both the edges held up but
Ben's is more finished more refined than
yours that's why we're letting you go I
agree
all right gentlemen good job you did a
lot of hard work in here Ben what's your
charity black horse porch it's a charity
that does three blacksmithing classes
for veterans and First Responders
congratulations that would be money well
spent come on
I feel really really good about the way
that my blade performed that's all that
I wanted was to come here and have a
strong showing Ben is a giant as a
competitor I love to beat somebody of
that caliber so it was a pleasure trying
to do it
um even though I didn't win